well remember that we have 20 um
conversion therapy laws that prohibit
them
from doing anything other than affirming
because that might be considered
you know the so-called conversion
therapy might be trying to convert them
out of being trans
now so in essence in essence they can
lose their license they could lose their
license
um now of course conversion therapy the
reason we passed these bans
was to it was to eliminate the really
ugly practices
of gay conversion therapy that's how
they got past
but they inserted activist inserted
gender identity language so now a
therapist can't even say to a child
hold on i know you say you're a boy but
let's explore some of the other things
that seem to be upsetting you
are you worried that the slippery slope
of this ultimately is that
you know a child will a a girl a young
girl will basically announce that she's
trans at school
a parent or the parents will say well
we're not transitioning you something
like that and then as the state grows
and again we're both in california
that literally the state will start
taking kids away from their parents like
is that
something that that you think is really
legit it's already happening
i mean just you especially hear that now
where where with divorce divorced
couples where they're not on the same
page
the i've had i've been called by a
mother who was
you know she was divorced but she had
full custody of the daughter
because the court deemed her the more
responsible better parent
and when the daughter hit 13 out of
nowhere she decided she was trans with
the encouragement of her therapist
and and her stepmom and the moment the
mom said the mom put the brakes on it
and said honey
you got look you know and and the mom
was not gender
conforming herself the mom said honey
look you're you're still a girl
just because you you know you don't want
to dress early that's fine
um then then the um a social worker was
brought in
and decided that um the mom was no
longer a safe parent
god i mean it's just it's it's twisted
it's deeply twisted what about on the
parent side where we've seen some
stories like this i can think of one
from about two months ago
where it really seems to be the parent
that's driving this that the stuff
we talked about earlier about oh you
suddenly are getting a lot of likes on
tumblr
or you're feeling like you're in a group
suddenly that we've heard some instances
where it seems like the parents are the
ones driving their children towards this
because then they
sort of by proxy feel popular or liked
or
or as an oppressed screw there they're
an oppressed group
adjacent or something right so i i think
that does happen
um the population i really looked at was
is the biggest population it's this teen
girl population and the re and
and there you don't you know these are
young women who aren't listening to mom
at all in fact the last thing they want
is advice for mom
and so usually in that instance the
parents aren't so much the driver
sometimes with the little kids
you do see parents who they you know who
seem to be pushing this
awfully hard and certain certainly seem
to be bragging about it online in ways
that
make you wonder if they aren't getting
something else out of it
yeah all right the shrinks are up next i
know that you're you're not thrilled
with the way therapists have dealt with
this
yeah i mean they have an affirmative
model right now the majority although i
interviewed look i interviewed you know
a lot of giants in the field who don't
agree with it and are not affirmative
therapists
but affirmative therapy says we start
from the conclusion
we know that we're going to agree with
that that a young person
who says they're gender dysphoric we're
going to agree that that's the right
diagnosis
will affirm them as transgender and the
only question is when do we get started
on the medications
and um you know that's that's just not
medicine
medicine is an evaluation of risks and
benefits
and the moment you are open about the
risks and benefits of
any medical treatment you're you're not
in the gender affirmative camp anymore
you're
you're on my side of things which is to
have an open look
and an approach with some skepticism how
these
girls are what and whether they're
benefiting so do you sense that the
that some of the psychologists or the
psychiatrist that they're actually
not telling these young girls the what
the numbers are in terms of
either regretting it later in life or
that it's not going to solve all of your
problems
or or that suicides are still high i
mean
all of these things that are
uncomfortable to talk about i mean do
you sense that they kind of hide that
because they're they're just on board
well
remember that we have 20 um conversion
therapy laws that prohibit them
from doing anything other than affirming
because that might be considered you
know the so-called conversion therapy
might be trying to convert them out of
being trans
now so in essence in essence they can
lose their license they could lose their
license
um now of course conversion therapy the
reason we passed these bands
was to it was to eliminate the really
ugly practices
of gay conversion therapy that's how
they got passed
but they inserted activist inserted
gender identity language so now a
therapist can't even say to a child
hold on i know you say you're a boy but
let's explore some of the other things
that seem to be upsetting you
yeah can you clean that up a little bit
for people that have nothing
no knowledge of any of this the sort of
difference between sexual
identity meaning your sexuality versus
verse gender identity and why
conversion in in each case or conversion
therapy in these cases is not exactly
apples to apples sure so with
homosexuality
you know um we've all you know we've
long
known that this is seems to be innate
and immutable
it's not the kind of thing you can sort
of convert someone out of or convince
them out of
and nor should you want to i mean this
is
there's nothing unhealthy about a gay
life there just
isn't but when you're talking about um
you know these the letting a child
become comfortable in their own body
because gender identity if a young woman
suddenly says i'm really a boy i need to
become a boy
you're setting them up to be a lifetime
medical patient
where they will put testosterone in
their bodies they need to stay on it for
life
it has all kinds of terribly extreme
side effects they're highly risky um
you know therapy that may make her
comfortable in her body
the today's therapy pushes her to
transition
um that's very different from from being
gay in which all the gay person asks is
that you accept
them from what you what they are what
what a you know what a trans teen asks
is you can you help me
try to be what i'm not and that's a much
more invasive intervention
yeah you know i'm reminded as you're
talking about this i'm blanking on
whether you mentioned the show in the
book did you talk about transparent at
all
the show no i didn't so the in there's a
line in the
last episode of the first season where
a woman who's already transitioned says
to the main character who's about to
begin the process
in effect this is going to ruin your
life this is going to ruin your family
and that in many ways is what the show
ended up being about now i know that's
not about a child transitioning
but i think a lot of what you're talking
about is just that so many people just
don't
have a holistic view of what this is
going to be like
on the other side that's exactly right
and when i interview transgender adults
who are very happy in their transitions
very often
they will still tell me look this is not
easy it's not easy to go through life
on all this hormonal treatment you know
holding yourself out as a member of the
opposite says
it's really hard and when when
transgender adults talk to me about it
they are horrified that teenagers are
getting this
so this this hormonal treatment so
easily without
any kind of understanding of the risks
and you know
and not appreciating how hard medical
transition really is
so all that being said chapter 7 is
about the dissidents there there are
some dissidents
in the field that's right a number of
prominent people have stood out and said
hold on
this is way too much way too fast with
too little medical oversight
um you know look the court found you
know and i
interviewed a lot of them including you
know ken zucker who chaired the
entry the the writing of the entry on
gender dysphoria for the dsm
five the the classic psychiatric manual
and on
mental disorders and um you know these
are people who say
starting with the conclusion is not
medicine
right and in fact last week um a the
british high court
examined the same protocols that they
have in place in britain for gender
medicine
and the the high court was appalled they
said you know
in effect what's been going on here is
likely to transition
a lot of young women who are not
supposed to be
transgender and a lot of you know young
people who are likely to experience
severe regret
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell